ist die seite live übertragung bis jetzt
noch nicht soll das seine leistung der
fahrer seinen wagen können sich gerne
interviews bei live ansonsten traurig
keiner medien ja es ist das ist eine
live-übertragung auf
[Musik]
mit nützlichen
haben sie kurz zeit wir versuchen so ein
kleines stimmungsbild zur deutschen
einheit in dresden einzufangen
es ist ja viel unseren anderen worten
hier abgestellt wurden
das ist nicht so wie sonst hier heute
als kürzlich hat die merkel jetzt aber
hier noch einmal nachgelegt was
fernsehen kommt wahrscheinlich nein ein
persönlicher traube der völlig ich
treffe toni den bundespolizei wer hier
ist ausgelassene stimmung wie sieht's
mit ihr auf hallo ich bin von russia
today kids waren sind sie heute hier
ich möchte verhindern dass man gar nicht
mehr erkennen ist untergang europas
untergang deutschlands untergang europas
das ist untergang was hier abläuft also
ich habe wenig verstanden aber was
standard war unter werden untergang euro
was will ich verhindern
ich finde es ist unglaublich was man ihr
macht dass man so viele reihen lässt es
geht einfach nicht dass naturgesetzlich
das ist eben die natur
ich meine auch in anderen dingen also
ist das so ein physikalisches gesetz
werden was runterfällt etwas kaputt
gemacht wird weil andere tag kommen ein
naturgesetz weil die tourismuszahlen
gegengeraden zurück wenn jetzt ein
tourist hierher kommen was würdest du
ihm empfehlen was man unbedingt sehen
die altstadt allgemein kann man sehr
viel sagen aber man muss jetzt sagen
nicht zum montag also montags dresden
meinen genau eben ist dadurch dass sich
der takt entscheidet ist eben das montag
tag genau zum montag und natürlich so
wie merkel wieder scheiße gebaut hätte
man wissen können dass am montag in
dresden fertig ist die live übertragung
bis jetzt noch nicht soll das eine
leistung der fahrer seinen wagen könnte
mich gerne interviews bei live ansonsten
traurig keiner medien
ja es ist eine live übertragung auch
arbeiter haben sie ja mein haus ist eine
ameise nicht und dann noch ein nur noch
eine jahr gut
also ich bin den menschen freundin
tierfreund dann schaffe ich dir ausmacht
sie nicht tot danach dreimal kommt zu
arbeiten die laufen dann durch überlegte
hier und und verstehen sie die masse
macht mich noch nicht gegen ausländer so
angela merkel hat nicht die gesamte
bundespolizei angefordert heute ist es
eher ruhig es ist ja auch eigentlich
nichts zu befürchten
es ist ja nicht feindliches gebiet oder
sowas sondern die menschen freuen sich
auf merkel
und deswegen braucht man eigentlich auch
keine polizei läuft unbedingt europa
immer noch immer noch
ja ich weiß nicht 20 jahren wird europa
muslimische sein und und dann und dann
sind muslimische land ja und was ist
jetzt das negative net/as das muslim ich
wird viele leute wissen gar nicht dass
frau merkel vor der wende das recht
hatte in die usa zu reisen
der verdacht dass diese frau ist ja ja
gerne diesmal wurden noch nie größere
und das ist erstmal bekanntmachen noch
die zeit zerrinnt
sie durfte in den westen fahren ist das
eine tatsache oder versagt ist jede
büchern
ich kann das natürlich nicht bestätigt
aber es steht den büchern im internet
noch eine andere frage sie feiern ihr ja
heute den tag der deutschen einheit wird
aber am dritten oktober war der
anschluss von österreich doch gar nicht
deutsche einheit von ost und west
das ist ja an der feier wo merkel und
auch teilnehmen nein das hier ist auch
deutschland
genauso ist genauso ist es 89 ja ich
dachte der anschluss von österreich wird
hier kommen sie dennoch so was ja das
ist doch eine prima demo hier oder nicht
auch rückt ja damit ist alles gesagt
nein ich habe auch gehört dass die usa
hinter der deutschen einheit steckt
es gibt bücher über die zahl ihrer
einsätze gebracht hat sich zu
weihnachten sozusagen ihr wisst ja hier
wird man direkt angegangen
meine mütze wurde geklaut jetzt ist
natürlich meine frisur durcheinander von
alten männern an getanzt und angegriffen
zu werden
aber was sollen wir machen
ich würde darauf hinweisen
dass man frau merkel ihre politik unter
dem gesichtspunkt betrachten sollte ob
sie vielleicht doch nicht
die kassen ist diese vorgibt sondern
eines ja eine erkenntnis
ich hab gehört man hat dir deine musik
laut wir kommen jetzt mal rum und
organisieren die wieder zurückwarfen
statt ich habe etwas organisiert im
studio ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut los hast
du scheiße fährt